[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara Heidi guten Abend in allen schön
dass Sie dabei sind wie auch Norbert
Lehmann für den Sport
Weltklimakonferenz in Ägypten gestartet
wie die Erderwärmung auf 1,5 Grad
begrenzen darum geht es zwei Wochen lang
in Sharm el-Sheikh
wahlkampfendsport in den USA zwei Tage
vor den Zwischenwahlen Ringen Demokraten
und Republikaner um die Mehrheit im
Kongress
ab Wahljahr oder Nein Spannung in
Frankfurt am Main es geht um die Zukunft
von Oberbürgermeister Feldmann
[Musik]
es ist die 27
Weltklimakonferenz die heute in Ägypten
begann mit 50.000 teilnehmenden morgen
kommen die Staats- und Regierungschefs
doch die Sorge ist groß das angesichts
all der anderen Krisen der Klimaschutz
zurückgestellt werden könnte dabei gab
es vor sieben Jahren so viel Hoffnung
2015 großer Jubel in Paris als sich 195
Staaten erstmals dazu bekannten die
Erderwärmung auf 1,5 Grad zu begrenzen
doch seither wurde viel zu wenig getan
der Klimawandel schreitet voran der
Gipfel in Ägypten könnte gegensteuern
Inga Rabe berichtet
draußen Sonnenschein im ägyptischen
Badeort Sharm el Sheikh und drinnen
schon ein Durchbruch noch nie zuvor
waren bei einer Welt Klimakonferenz die
Schäden von Naturkatastrophen und deren
Kosten ein offizieller verhandlungspunkt
das Thema wird auf der Tagesordnung
behandelt und insofern ist das glaube
ich ein erstes Zeichen der Zuversicht
dass wir hier auch in Sharm el Sheikh
gerade bei diesem wichtigen Thema für
die Entwicklungsländer Vorankommen auch
wenn sie selbst kaum zum Klimawandel
beigetragen haben die Folgen treffen vor
allem ärmere Länder hart oft bleiben sie
auch auf den Kosten sitzen wie wichtig
es ist dass sich die Klimakonferenz in
großer Runde um diesen Punkt kümmert
zeigt der neue Bericht der
Weltorganisation der Meteorologen je
stärker die Erderwärmung umso stärker
die Auswirkungen für die Welt
zeigt sehr klar dass der Klimawandel mit
katastrophaler Geschwindigkeit
voranschreitet zerstörerisch für die
Lebensbedingungen auf jedem Kontinent
deshalb müssen wir die Menschen dringend
vor den Risiken des klimanotfalls
Schützen doch bei der Begrenzung der
Erderwärmung gibt es einige Knackpunkte
in kriegs- und Krisenzeiten bringt zwar
der Wunsch nach Unabhängigkeit
erneuerbare Energien kräftig voran aber
in vielen Ländern droht auch eine
Renaissance der fossilen Brennstoffe für
die nächsten zwei Wochen genug
Diskussionsstoff auf dem Weltklimagipfel
[Applaus]
vor Ort was sind die Erwartungen an
diese Klimakonferenz
die Erwartungen sind groß das
Gastgeberland Ägypten hat sich hier ein
eisernes Ziel gesetztes will die
Umsetzung der klimaversprechend sehen
die vergangenes Jahr gemacht wurden also
ganz konkret wie viel weit wird
aufgeforstet wie viele Emissionen werden
gestrichen wie finanzieren die
industrielände die Anpassungsmaßnahmen
der Entwicklungsländer an den
Klimawandel es wurde ja viel versprochen
100 Milliarden Dollar jährlich wurde den
Entwicklungsländern versprochen doch
bislang haben sie nur einen begrenzten
Teil davon gesehen und dass er zu
Verärgerung geführt als Fürsprecher der
afrikanischen Nationen drängt Ägypten
außerdem auch auf ganz konkrete
Entschädigungszahlungen bei aktuellen
Klimaschäden und das dürfte die
Nagelprobe dieser Konferenz werden der
Hauptstreitpunkt morgen dann die
offizielle Eröffnung es werden über 100
Staats- und Regierungschefs erwartet
auch Bundeskanzler Scholze wird morgen
hier den ägyptischen Präsidenten treffen
vielen Dank
in die USA Präsident Joe Biden Nancy
Schicksalswahl obwohl er gar nicht zur
Wahl steht am Dienstag sind
Kongresswahlen und wenn seine Demokraten
wie erwartet einen Dämpfer bekommen wird
das Regieren für beiden noch schwieriger
als Wahlkampfhelfer setzt er auch auf
seinen populären Vorgänger Barack Obama
Benjamin Daniel berichtet
demokratischer wahlkampfentspurt in
Pennsylvania einem der schlüsselstaaten
im Kampf um den US-Senat Barack Obama
und Joe Biden sind gekommen der
Präsident warnt vor Hass und Lügen die
viele Republikaner immer aggressiver
verbreiten
es ist eine Abstimmung über Demokratie
ein entscheidender Moment für unsere
Nation wir alle müssen mit einer Stimme
sprechen unabhängig von der Partei der
wir anhängen in Amerika hat politisch
motivierte Gewalt keinen Platz
Wahrheit Fakten und Logik stehen zur
Abstimmung genauso wie Vernunft und
Anstand
wir stimmen über Demokratie selbst ab es
steht viel auf dem Spiel
nicht weit entfernt wird Donald Trump
für seine Kandidaten und greift in
seiner Rede all jene an die sein
Weltbild nicht teilen
die Zeit gegen die größer werdende linke
Tyrannei aufzubegehren ist genau jetzt
wenn ihr eure Rechte und Freiheiten
behalten wollt müsst ihr den radikalen
Linken bei der Wahl am Dienstag einen
richtig demütigenden Denkzettel
verpassen
es steht viel auf dem Spiel nach letzten
Umfragen könnten die Demokraten beide
kongresskammern verlieren was es ihnen
noch schwerer machen würde ihre Vorhaben
umzusetzen
mögliche vorteilsname peinliche
Auftritte sexistische Sprüche die Liste
der Vorwürfe gegen Frankfurts
Oberbürgermeister Peter Feldmann ist
lang heute konnten die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger abstimmen ob der SPD-Politiker im
Amt bleibt fällt man steht seit Monaten
wegen zahlreicher Fehltritte in der
Kritik auch in seiner eigenen Partei
wegen des Verdachts der vorteilsname
muss sich der 64-Jährige vor Gericht
verantworten
Stefan Schlösser ist im Rathaus in
Frankfurt gibt es schon erste Prognosen
ob Feldmann im Amt bleiben kann oder
nicht
ja also zur Zeit zeichnet sich eine
deutliche Mehrheit von über 90 Prozent
ab die für die Abwahl von Peter Feldmann
als Oberbürgermeister gestimmt haben
aber das allein das reicht ja noch nicht
denn insgesamt müssen 30 Prozent aller
Wahlberechtigten für die Abwahl stimmen
das sind rund 150.000 Menschen und ob
dieses Quorum erreicht wird das ist noch
nicht klar im Moment liegt die
Wahlbeteiligung nur bei etwas über 20
Prozent das wäre dann zu wenig
allerdings sind viele Briefwahlstimmen
noch nicht ausgezielt die können das
Ergebnis noch mal maßgeblich verändern
also wie geht es weiter noch nicht ganz
klar Peter Feldmann wird sich hier
nachher vor der Öffentlichkeit erklären
und dann wird er sagen wir das Ergebnis
bewertet egal wie das jetzt ausgeht
entweder bleibt er im Amt weil das Forum
nicht reicht oder er muss gehen wenn er
bleiben will man kann sich kaum
vorstellen wie das eigentlich
funktionieren wollen viele Bürger wollen
ihn nicht die eigene Partei die SPD die
Regierungsparteien wollen die nicht mehr
im Amt haben also bis zusammen
offiziellen amtsende im Juni 2024 könnte
bei einem Verbleib von Peter Feldmann
als Oberbürgermeister das könnten zwei
mü viele Jahre hier in der Frankfurter
Politik werden Dankeschön für diese
Einschätzung Stefan Schlösser
Italien hat zwei rettungsschiffen die
Einfahrt in einen sizilianischen Hafen
gewährt in der Nacht zum Sonntag legte
die deutsche humanity 1 mit 179
Migranten in Catania an allerdings ließ
die neue italienische Regierung nur
Minderjährige und Kranke von Bord am
Nachmittag gab es dann auch für einen
norwegisches Schiff mit 572 Migranten
grünes Licht zwei weitere Schiffe mit
geretteten Haaren noch immer im
Mittelmeer aus
und jetzt sind wir beim Sport beim
Skispringen im polnischen Whistler
erstmals ein Weltcup auf grünen Matten
statt auf Schnee ja und im grünen
Bereich heute auch die Leistung der
deutschen Frauen während die Männer
enttäuschend ganz starke Leistung von
Katharina Althaus gestern nur 21 heute
dagegen sprang sie aus Podest besser war
nur eine Österreicherin
lautstarker Jubel bei Eva pinkelnik über
ihren vierten Weltcupsieg beim auf
Matten ausgetragenen zweiten Springen
des weltcup-auftakts in Wisla zeigt die
34-Jährige Österreicherin zwei starke
Sprünge Weiten von 129 und 128 einhalb
Meter bedeuten den Sieg
für den ersten Höhepunkt im deutschen
Skisprung Winter sorgt Katharina Althaus
die 26-Jährige aus Oberstdorf springt im
zweiten Durchgang einen neuen
Schanzenrekord 131 m Alter aus landet
auf Platz 2 den dritten Platz sichert
sich die Schwedin Frieda Westmann
zweitbeste deutsche Springerin heute in
Polen Selina Freitag auf Rang 19
im ersten Sonntagsspiel der
Fußball-Bundesliga hat Union Berlin mit
0 zu 5 in Leverkusen verloren ja und
damit die Tabellenführung nach sieben
Spieltagen an der Spitze abgegeben an
Rekordmeister Bayern München zu den
turnweltmeisterschaften in Liverpool da
hat Lukas Dauser am waren Silber geholt
übrigens die einzige deutsche Medaille
bei dieser WM
die Gewissheit eines souveränen
Auftritts Lukas Dauser hat seine
anspruchsvolle Barrenübung selten so auf
den Punkt geturnt wie heute Nachmittag
in Liverpool dem deutschen gelingt einer
zu fehlerfreier Vortrag inklusive seines
Abgangs Doppelseite vorwärts mit halber
Drehung
am Ende
15,500 Punkte für die 29-Jährigen
lediglich der Olympiasieger aus China
ist besser jinjuan Zoo erhält 6/10 mehr
und wird zum dritten Mal Weltmeister
Lukas Dauser freut sich wie bei Olympia
in Tokio über die Silbermedaille
wie schön danke schön
fehlt noch das Wetter im Osten und Süden
gibt es größere sonnige Abschnitte sonst
oft bewölkt und gelegentlich etwas Regen
bei kräftigem Südwestwind 11 bis 18 Grad
Christian Sievers freut sich auf Sie im
heute-journal um viertel vor zehn hier
übernimmt morgen Jana pareigis wir sagen
tschüss wünschen Ihnen einen guten Start
in die neue Woche